hallo zam das ist Q&A zu Meer Reportage
zum Thema Berufstätige Väter Angst vor
dem Karriereknick danke für mal für die
viele Kommentar und auch die Liebe
private nachrichtte auf es paar von der
Reaktionen würde ich jetzt gerne
der Philip hat z. B geschbe als nächstes
bitte eine Reportage mit Vätern die zu
100% zu Hause sind und die Mütter
arbeiten dies würde mich sehr
interessieren vi gerne mal meine erste
Film wo zum Thema verbarkeit für Job und
Kind be junge Müter gegangen ist da ich
nmlich ein Familie denin wo der Vater
hauptsächlich der hei ist und mi 100%
schaffet es paar sind die den kommentarf
egangen dass sie findet dass es sehr
viel privilegier die Protagonist in
Reportage h so z.Bp wie wäre es wenn man
mal Personen Filmen würde die nicht
gerade Anwälte oder Agenturpartner sind
ich glaube dort ist der Druck größer und
Wünsche von pensumreduktion oder
Traumjob bleiben eben nur Träume h das
gesehen ich genau aus so es gibt sehr
viel Familien wo sich einfach aus
finanziell gründ nicht Leiste ausuche
wie sie ihres pensumw aufteilen in M
Film ist es aber genau drum Gang be den
Herzl wo abön selbst bestimmt auswählen
weil das Modell sie w ich das Thema
Angst vor dem karriereeknick Aufgen und
hab mich darum genau für Protagonist
entschieden wo abön ausl wie sie w
machen und die finanzielle Mittel hattet
und da finde ich aber gerade spannend
das ffallt dass ich vi wo e Mittel hatet
den trotzdem für das ihr traditionelles
Modell entscheidet oder einfach für das
höchst Pensum und genau drum habe ich
mich für dir protagoniste entscheen und
nicht für andere es ist mir aber auch
bewusst dass es andere Situationen geht
so schriet nämlich z.Bp
pladina wir fünfköpfige Familie mein
Mann gut Verdiener 100% ich schlecht
verdienerin zu Hause ich würde so gerne
arbeiten gehen und er würde so gerne
reduzieren finanziell ist es nicht
möglich da wir finanzielle einb wen
hätten Betreuung ist viel zu teuer und
ich würde das verlorene Geld bei einem
reduzierten Pensum nicht reinbringen das
ist für ein Land wie die Schweiz
wahnsinnig traurig und ja das hab ich
natürlich schon auch oft gehört dass es
einfach sich nicht lohnt wenn Frau dann
irgendwie nur 20% oder 40% schaff das
Geld wo sie verdient dann z.B gerade die
Kita würde in Flüßen bin wirklich
bewusst dass es das auch geht aber das
ist einfach nicht der Fokus von mir Film
gie zu dem Gedanke von der gut verdien
hätte andreasis geschrieben wie wäre es
den Begriff arbeitskarriere in
lebenskarriere umzuwandeln es gibt viel
mehr zu entdecken als nur den
beruflichen Fortschritt Zeit mit Kindern
Ehrenamt oder eben freie Zeit aber das
bracht Mut weil viele den
wirtschaftlichen leistungsideal
hinterherpringen gerade gutverdienende
hätten einen großen Spielraum wenn sie
denn nur wollten finde ich ein schöner
asatz kann man sich ja mal Gedanken dazu
machen den auf das Gang W ich am Schluss
von der Reportage erwähnt dass ich mir
wie würde Wechsel Wünsche in der K V der
arbeitgabber aber auch V der
arbeitnmer und zwar schiebt die Person
der Switch im System kommt von den
Menschen selbst wenn alle Männer darauf
warten dass der Arbeitgeber jetzt bitte
Teilzeit möglich macht dann wird sich
nichts tun hey ich se auch so dass es
aber von beiden sie her es umdenk
braucht vi der Firma z.B sind
hauptsälich männerestellt und sie sind
einfach wie noch nicht so gewöhnt dass
man vielleicht auch andere Modell Kön
die umsetze und drum glaube ich wir
brauch aber schon Offenheit vom
arbeitgabber aber auch irgendwie ein
gewisse behhaarlichkeit vo der VAT wo
dann einfachf best dass sie z.B wenn du
auf 80% reduzieren und ich glaube es
braucht wirklich beides dass es am
Schluss funktioniert die offheit ist
nlich leider noch nicht überall Vorhand
so schriebt z.B der Lorenz die Realität
ist dass ich gerade vor vier Stunden ein
intern Bewerbungsgespräch auf eine
kaderstelle hatte ich habe leider ich
habe aber leider eine Absage erhalten
nicht etwa wegen meiner Fähigkeiten
sondern viel mehr weil ich nicht bereit
bin 100% zu arbeiten dann ist schf egang
auf der catchy Titel Kind oder Karriere
und Z die Person ja entweder Kind oder
Karriere beides geht leider nicht und
ich glaube ich sehe das anders ich hab
Gefühl gerade wenn es in kaderpition
auch 60 oder 80% W die gab oder z.B
jobsaring war viel mehr möglich dass man
sich in Position wenn man Kind h und nzu
hab ich a Gefühl wenn den der unternahme
VAT z. reduzier geht sie auch wieder me
P für
mü aufstocken und drum hab ich gefh muss
man sch umdenk und
dazulich Miriam hey mit 30% Karriere
machen ich positiontiegen mit 30% und
darf jetzt als Projektleiterin schaffen
und ich kannine zwei Kind als Mami
trotzdem vollkommen gcht werde und im
Job würde ich sagen auch ich glaub das
ist auch gerade schön Schlusswort dass
man aber so undanken braucht einfach
nmer nur in dem traditionell Karriere
kann man nur mit 100% mache denke drin
steckt und da braucht einfach vieles es
braucht System g kommt arbeitgabber aber
auch P und mütere wo da wie zam spannen
und familiefreundliche Modell finden
das ist es jetzt sch V Q&A wenn i nch
mehr Frage oder meinige sch unbedingt
die Kommentare schriftlich draf und ich
verlinke noch mal meine erste Film zum
Thema Job und Kind zu welchem Preis W mü
gegangen ist mich freu
[Musik]
wenn